[Music]
welcome to Crewe biscuits I'm Stevie and
I'm Kevin and today at the round table
of dim lighting we are talking all about
Kevin Kevin related topics only at this
table Kevin thank you for being here I
didn't give you much of a choice yeah
thank you for having me Kevin related
topics are my favourite time I must
disclose I just I just walked into the
studio and said that I wet my hat and
that's because I literally put water on
my hat and you can see it and I don't
want comments about what that could be
it's water I don't know what else I said
I've been sweating like a pig so it's
hot it's a hot one it is hot yeah it's
really hot outside we were shooting
yesterday outside in downtown Pomona the
entire day and at a certain point your
brain like ceases to work like my
emailing cuz I I sit in the video
village in the in a chair and they have
a portable Wi-Fi and I just have my
computer and I'm just reviewing videos
and watching bloody system at the same
time and at a certain point I was just
like cannot cannot process the notes
that need to be come out of my body onto
this that sounded drugs and that is not
what's on my hat I usually go for walks
to get a little exercise in here at work
every day like around like around the
like Burbank area just around it's
beautiful in the Burbank area yeah and
yesterday I went out and it was like 100
degrees or close to and I went around
the corner here you know like 100 feet
that way to the left we don't want to
disclose what corner no but the one here
closest to the door yeah and then I went
about another 200 feet and I saw Mike
sitting down on a brick wall like in a
tiny patch of shade and I said he said
hey Kevin and I said hey Mike and I was
like what do you do and he's like I
tried to go for a walk and this is also
another fun fact before we go any
further there's a graphic on the mic
right here that looks like a little but
oh yes I do have a bite graphic do you
know what that means
hey no oh
good guess but it means like that is
where in order to get the best sound of
this out of this mic you have to talk
right into the middle of it because the
other butt area that's not in the crack
/ hole is bad but area to talk in okay
well I will aim straight for the crack
of the butt and I'll talk into it
thank you so I said this last time on
crew biscuits but just to reiterate we
are doing crew biscuits and other crew
themed podcasts while we're in
production on buddy system
we're also production and production on
various other things there are always so
many things going on this morning you
participated in what was almost a brawl
outside of my office door to get in to
meet with me because I'm very popular
yes you won I did win I had to bypass a
knee though yes normally what we do is
we go to Annie and we say Annie I need a
tux TV and then she says she looks at
the schedule and then she says I can get
you in at this time and sometimes when
Annie's not looking and I see your door
open I just charged full speed into it
and I did that today and it worked
because Annie couldn't stop me she was
just like and then I slammed the door
and she could do nothing about it but
that's why crew biscuits exists as I
said before I have no time we all are
busy and I am the worst at having a
moment to sit down and talk to you guys
and so that's why I wanted to take this
opportunity I I also realize like half
an hour ago the amount of stories that I
know about you I think the percentage of
the ones that are appropriate to talk
about on the show that percentage is
very low but we'll get some of the
stories out so instead of going back to
your birth story let's not talk about
your birth story
oh that's seems like odd like we'll go
back to like when you were a kid more
about my parents anyways but like yeah
yeah I want to talk about when I first
met you okay because I went back through
my inbox and
you had sent an email to us in December
of 2014
yep we're looking for a producer and
editor for ear biscuits which is this
podcast kind of yes and I have your
resume
oh no the cover letter that you wrote so
ear biscuits I mean I feel like and you
know what's so weird is that I was like
Kevin is an OG mythical crewmember like
I feel like you've been here for a very
long time I think there was like eight
people that worked here when I started
yeah and it was like forever ago
and we were at our old studio old studio
which was not a studio at all it was
like a house it's like a it was like a
weird like the back part was like
someone's apartment yes
and then the front part was like it
seemed like a dental like a really bad
dental facility or yeah that is what if
I were they like gave you drugs yes it
was definitely a drug facility of some
sort and you open the door and there's
just a wall and you're like oh and
there's like a staircase that goes up
and you're like okay I guess I go that
way my biggest memory of that like
specific little entry room that you're
talking about and I don't mean to throw
this person under the bus but I doubt
that they're listening to this we had
someone that was working for us for a
very short period of time that mailed a
package to ourselves oh yes and I just
in my mind like I see that entryway and
I just see the package I was the one who
found it and I was like anyway um so
then I was like well but when did your
biscuits start except I looked at the
wiki page for ear beside September 2013
and that origin story according to the
wiki page the origin story of ear
biscuits is that they wanted to like
tape their marriage counseling sessions
which don't exist but they wanted to
okay you have them on the podcast I
don't even remember that being even a
joke but according to the wiki page
that's how the origin story is but it
was more like I was like hey we should
do a podcast and they really like
no and I was like come on we should
really do a podcast and they were like
met and then they came in one day and
we're like remember how you were asking
if we should do a podcast we're gonna do
that guessed it anyway so from September
2013 all the way until January 2015 when
you joined our editing system was a
little bit odd yeah and and so like I
was I was producing the show booking the
guests doing the research for people and
then I was paper editing the show yeah
and I remember I have an Instagram post
from Harley epic mealtimes episode and
it's every f-bomb that he said on the
show the timecode of it yep like there
were some like inventive curse words and
it's just a sheet of paper with just
like really horrible curse words all
over it with time codes doesn't surprise
me but anyway he started and January
2015
and you took everything over from me and
it was amazing I did yes I have to tell
you how I got the email okay but I don't
know if you want to talk about the email
so it's it's a bit of a long story but
I'll I'll keep it to the highlights okay
so this might step on some things you're
gonna ask me soon though are we going
back are we going back into like we're
going back but you can go back before I
go back we can go back together they
don't have to be the back that goes back
let me line up the spot crack here and
we'll go back okay so are you gonna have
a different boy no I'm gonna keep the
same I don't have other voices okay I
only have one voice so that email went
through like five which email are you
talking to you know that you sent out
looking for okay a producer of ear
biscuits okay it took I went through
like four or five people before it got
to me and went through two of my friends
before it gets to me yeah you never knew
this no I kept this secret until now cuz
I knew one day I'd be on the ear
biscuits podcast telling you crew
biscuit crew biscuit so I had been doing
some editing work some freelance in Los
Angeles and when the work it was always
like out here it's always feast or
famine
so I was in famine mode and I wasn't
getting any work so I started putting
out feelers to a bunch of my friends and
I was saying hey if anything pops up in
line of editing or anything just let me
know and I started getting desperate
because like nothing was coming up oh
thanks
no like I I had a Trader Joe's
application in the trunk of my car
and I was also collecting unemployment
at this time so I went through great
feast times and then I just hit like
this slump and I was also kind of
itching to get back into working with a
team as well instead of freelance
editing by myself it got kind of
tiresome and lonely so I was also
looking for something specific to and
then I finally got a forward message
from my friend
it was this email from Stevie and the
friend was so when I came out to Los
Angeles see now I think I'm taking over
your questions here probably like when
I'm anxious about my questions okay so I
moved out to LA like eight years ago
and just wanting to do something in the
entertainment industry but okay okay
yeah I'm not this isn't a question but
you're from Lancaster you're from yes a
very close place to LA Lancaster English
California it's like an hour outside of
Los Angeles it's um if you've ever seen
like a car commercial where it's all
desert and like Joshua trees is
Lancaster I mean they have basically
just like seven Walmart's and it's a lot
of water yeah they have a lot of
Walmart's out there Wow it's just Joshua
trees and Walmart Joshua trees and
Walmart's okay we'll get back to
Lancaster I just wanted to set it up for
the people that like us you moving out
to LA was was that that type of yes
situation born in Pittsburgh moved to
Lancaster California at three months old
so raised in Lancaster all they upped
was twenty and because you're only an
hour outside of LA I knew at a very
young age that I wanted to be in the
entertainment industry in fact I knew
when I was in the seventh grade because
my neighbor across the street his aunt
lent us their video recorder and it was
like one of those old skis Colin
Flintstone cameras but they're the ones
you like put a VHS tape in and put it in
your shoulder has like the eyepiece and
you have to do like in camera editing
where you stuff in wine and since we got
that camera we started making
little funny sketch videos and it's the
only consistent thing I've done my whole
life is like make videos so I knew then
that that's what I wanted to do but I
had no connections in LA I had no family
in the business my family was always
lower middle-class relatively poor
growing up so I couldn't even they
couldn't like buy me a camera to do
stuff so this is all off of someone's
like borrowed camera and like a borrowed
computer that a neighbor had they were
making these videos but I was very
passionate about it and what but like
that's good dive in example because I'm
thinking like the only time I ever used
cameras like that it was always Barbies
like I was always can but there was
always Barbies and they were talking to
each other and then you know there was
no other possible it was just I think it
was you could shoot Barbies and then
that's all you could do I have to
Murphy's right I was all Barbies in fact
we did use some Barbies but I have two
VHS tapes at home that are just labeled
commercials on them because when I was a
kid when we started doing these he
started making commercials we made
commercials basically so we did and we
did a Got Milk commercial and we did a
mr. Rogers commercial and we did a lot
of action figure stuff mr. Rogers like
in earnest or like it was making fun of
totally making fun but also like an O
Maj because I love mr. Rogers growing up
yeah so it was kind of both
[Music]
well today kids we might be going to ice
cream factory and look how they make ice
cream
[Music]
and we started the older we got the kind
of weirder they got I went through a
wrestling phase where I was really into
wrestling so we have buried somewhere
some wrestling videos hmm where I have
um like characters that I of the
wrestler that I was because I swore that
I was going to be a wrestler one day Wow
yeah
drones bug gonna get your ropes
oh shoot blanks picks up a share
Oh Danks him in the head bring it
through a wrestling phase in fact I met
the rock I met Dwayne Johnson during my
wrestling phase my mom let me ditch
school one day so I could go and wait in
line for four hours in downtown LA to
meet the rock at a book signing Wow and
I told him that I would see him in the
ring one day so we ever get Dwayne
Johnson on the show you have to let me
tell him my story I have I have his book
signed it's proof I thought that you
were just like in fact I met the rock
and then you were gonna stop there and
like it was like a bragging moment and I
was like I don't know where to go from
here Kevin I was bragging but no this
will this will all get back to the email
here and it's it'll all make sense I
program so you're you're making you're
making little videos on this VHS
Flintstones camera editing them on
remember those old Macs the big like
yeah huge Macintosh Apple computers that
were like colored like neon really my
neighbor had one so I would use his cuz
again like my family was kind of poor
and they couldn't buy me how would that
work so does the video camera have like
a cord that connects it to the computer
because I only did the mini DV like many
TVs were right when I owe ya so the
first phase of making these videos was
VHS tape editing on camera so if we
messed up a take heed rewind so you'd
always see like a short clip of the mess
up and they would like scramble and then
cut to the new take and we have my
friend I did it with my friends Brian
and Sean they were like my best friends
growing up across the street and he one
of them who's a musician
would be on a keyboard doing like music
and sound effects is the background so
that's that was the first like
installment of videos as time went on
and they started the VHS tapes tape
started getting smaller and smaller and
then we got the computer they had like I
think it was like a firewire cable or
something yeah plug right in and that
was I just wanted
want to know what the set of the program
we use yes and that was like a
revelation because then I remember being
able to put in a song in a video was
like in titles that was the coolest
thing in the world to me I remember the
first time I edited anything in that way
I was in the Edit Bay for like I must
have been like over it overnight and it
was like a 60 second fake intro for
something that had a meetin the head of
music track behind it and I remember
being very excited but also like very
frustrated that it had taken me that so
long to do place yeah I don't even know
how we did it we just it just all
self-taught everything I've ever done
editing has been self-taught and just
learning off of people that are really
good at it so you ditched wrestling did
yeah the video thing was where you
wanted to go yes because there was a
phase and they're wrestling got over
that phase and we continued making
videos and I it sort of attracted all of
the friends that I had like the older I
got I would take whatever video court
like in high school there was a video
class like the school show that they did
every morning like the announcements so
I took that class and we got to make
sketches for that and then junior
college I went to analog value college
which was a mile from my parents house
shout out shout out to a VC had some
good teachers there and I took a bunch
of film classes there I did a bunch of
film projects there and made some good
friends there as well and then after
that I applied and went to San Francisco
State University and I went there for
two years and I went there for Creative
Writing because I I was also as I was a
filmmaker and I was writing sketches I
really liked writing too and so I
thought for school I had two friends my
two best friends not Ryan and John other
two best friends that I made they're all
my best friends they actually were all
my groomsmen at my wedding oh really all
my best so nice but like Kevin's really
nice so um oh they told me to stop not
banging on the desk I'm sorry Maggie I
can't
I know not to do you don't control me so
I went to school for a creative writing
and I went with Benny and Toni and I was
there for two years went with friends
from home that also friends from home we
all like applied together and we got in
like just in the nick of time because we
were short three credits for a math
class and we had the one teacher there
that everybody said is easy because I am
terrible at math horrible
I took one math class my first semester
and it was something like embarrassing
like like algebra two or something and I
was failing and I was like oh gosh so I
took statistics have you ever are bad at
math and you need the credits take
statistics yeah that's a great advice we
had to take a Saturday morning class it
was the only one available and we took
that and barely passed but got the
credits we needed to go to San Francisco
and I was working for I was working at a
movie theater because you know the whole
movie thing and I was also working at
Technicolor film lab which was in its
informatics core North Hollywood and I
got that job because I was a
projectionists at the movie theater and
a friend of mine said hey do you want to
come and do projection down at
Technicolor it's a union job and I was
like 18 years old finishing up school
wanting to go to you know University and
I thought sure why not and it was great
it was like 32 bucks an hour job and it
was I was the youngest person doing
projection at Technicolor the youngest
person at Technicolor and my job was to
as I'm going off in a little side
tangent but I promise we'll get to this
email my job there was to run like after
they printed the reels for movies
I would thread them up in a projector
and then play them for color timers to
make sure that the prints look good I
think now they send out DVDs and stuff
to theaters or like discs or something
to theaters that using film is not as
much anymore so I knew that being that
true but I will just not the figure that
I worked at Cinemark 22 in Lancaster
shellow California shoutout oh we do
shoutouts on crew biscuits
okay made that up last time we we
shouted out um who do we shout out last
time I I shouted out
Jennifer Lawrence I just you know so you
can shop you can shout out the rock and
Antelope Valley High School Valley
College yep Lancaster high school is
where we don't have to shout them out
okay
no they're great so then we passed the
math class I was working for Technicolor
I was working for at the movie theaters
I was working two jobs and going to
school full-time pretty much and the
Technicolor job I would thread it up
play it for the color timer just to make
sure the print looked good so they could
send it off to the theaters and often
you would be running them for you would
be running dailies for the
cinematographers sometimes the directors
would come in it was like high-profile
people like Clint Eastwood would come in
and I remember doing the terminal and
the Spielberg movie and the I don't know
if it was it was one of the producers I
threaded it up upside down and I didn't
know and I was like my first week every
projector and there was different
it was I would 18 years old pretty sure
I developed acid reflux for nerves being
there and I hit I hit start ran it and I
went to the other projector to thread up
the next reel and apparently they were
trying to call me on the phone but the
phone wasn't working so then I turn
around and the guy is has the phone in
his hand and he's banging on the window
with it and he's screaming at me but
there's soundproof so I can't hear him
so I see that it's upside down and I'm
like oh God so I had to call the chief
projectionists to help me and he ran
down he held me when it was over the guy
came out and basically just talked crap
about me for a while and wanted to you
to my boss wanting to play safe I say I
don't like he put it in upside down yes
yeah sorry
and that's the chief my boss was really
cool he just came in he's like don't
sweat it that was all he said to me I
liked the idea of someone abusing the
chief about something that was he was
like chief projectionists always just
call him chief okay so I ended up making
some money from that job enough to where
I could go to school in San Francisco or
join the Union and be a full-time
projectionists I went to school because
San Francisco
ways more enticing to me and because
always go to school kids yes cool it was
like school especially in San Francisco
it's so expensive now and it was at the
time I was there but not nearly as bad
and I had a great two years there it was
an incredible experience and then I
moved back home as you do after college
not knowing what to do I just had a
degree in creative writing which I mean
what are you gonna do with that I was
going to ask you if your if your parents
if your parent if you were pushed into
creative writing because they don't want
you to go into video or one cut one of
you know the families that are like no
you can't get a degree in that but you
have to get a degree in this but before
I get that answer I want to let you know
about this t-shirt that you could get at
rhettandlink.com/store it doesn't come
with hair or with a flannel over it but
it does come with Altamont coolness can
you see this Maggie can you see how cool
it is it's very pewter blocking I can
vouch for Stevie it is a really cool
shirt it's I want my GMM that's a
reference to MTV for the young people
out there who don't know that you will
wear this and you will be very cool oh
my gosh Kevin what is that oh well
Stevie I'm so glad you asked because
this right here is a once in a lifetime
only mug mm-hmm the boiled for safety
mug you said the one and only I was like
no I totally didn't say that but the
same effect it's this is a great mug I
drink out of this mug every day if there
was liquid in it right now I would be
drinking out of it there's not but but
show them how you drink air out of it
some people love air I'll do it to my
camera also that is great hey look at
the bottom of that mug did you see that
there's a hidden little logo in there
it's for a show called good mythical
morning as is this t-shirt and you can
get the t-shirt and the mug at
rhettandlink.com/store Wow I am again
just struck with how great that ad was
and my general ability
I mean annual
this is the second time for me to do it
so I'm just saying it was a good at
things at rhettandlink.com/store solid
as great product so you're absolutely
the teaser was did your family bully you
into one degree or another when it when
it came to college and the answer is a
very simple no my parents are really
awesome I was very lucky with great
parents and great brothers great family
so no they supported me in any endeavor
I have ever wanted to go on they would
back it for me it was just always a
balance between I love writing and I
love editing and filmmaking and the two
are mutually exclusive but when you go
to school you got to pick one or the
other
yeah and I just chose writing I was just
in the phase of it at the time I am just
to talk about myself for a second please
I too knew that I wanted to be in the
entertainment industry but when I was a
kid
I either wanted to be an actor that is
not something that as I grew older I was
comfortable with in fact that was the
other thing I wanted to talk about is as
soon as the cameras start rolling
I get very self-conscious which people
have commented on gmm likewise TV always
hiding behind something well it's a lot
easier that way I wanted to be an actor
an entertainment lawyer oh or a producer
okay and I feel like my parents were
like and there were like please be an
entertainment lawyer but I did I chose
in between right the two that I could
have anyway that's all back to Kevin hey
back to me now I'm gonna keep on
rambling so I after school I move back
home as you do and I was trying to
figure out what to do and I bounced
around a lot of random jobs I have
worked a lot of random jobs a lot of
retail jobs so general ones are like
Blockbuster Video is so cool I was just
thinking about when I was little I would
go to Blockbuster at least once or twice
oh yeah but it would get to the point
where I had seen everything on the
shelves like I as soon as I saw a movie
that I hadn't seen I was like is this
appropriate for me to watch because I
haven't seen
and it looks good when I worked at
Blockbuster they let you have five free
rentals a week that's pretty that's uh
that means no social life
that means no social life lots and lots
of movies I as I worked at the movie
theater I worked for Tower Records for a
brief time you had really cool job yeah
and I feel like if I looked at myself I
would understand that as well yes and
but that's I mean you're a lot cooler
than I well I also worked for t-mobile
for a while and I worked for I hung
posters for a local fair once for a
while got my first paycheck doing that I
wrote music reviews for a website called
prefix mag shoutout
and I got my first check as a writer
from prefix mag for six dollars six
dollars for $1 for writing one article
yes but hey it was kind of cool I was
like I got paid for writing that's cool
yeah and and then I worked for a hotel
company for a long time I saw that on
your resume that I have a very long time
and that was like I chose that because I
thought about going to grad school but
this job popped up and I thought I can
travel with this job and I did like I
got to go to Holland I got to go to
Ireland
my first trip to New York and I went to
Napa Valley had a lot of cool trips from
that job so it was good for what it was
and then finally my friend Benny who I
went to college with Tony still missed
yes Tony is still still in college no
he's still in San Francisco because that
is a long student yes no Tony still in
San Francisco a long student that make
sense right
so Benny finished grad school and then
he said I'm moving to LA and I want you
to move in with me and I was like I want
to do that too but I'm working at this
hotel job and I you know it's a long
commute and I don't know if I want to do
it but because he Benny was in the same
boat he wanted to be an actor and he
knew I wanted to do work in the
entertainment industry so he was like
look I'm gonna move now and you I think
my recommendation is for you to move
here with me and then you can start
looking for what you really want to do
because you'll be here and you just
won't keep putting it off and it was
actually really great advice so I did
have to commute for a while but I was
actively looking for stuff here in town
because I was trying to figure out how
like you you know the infamous saying of
like getting your foot in the door
someone yeah which is the hardest thing
to do when you have no connections and
no family members it weren't Technicolor
I wasn't technically so the youngest
projection is ever there so I moved out
here and we us we joined a sketch comedy
group called good form Peter a shout out
they're dead now they no longer exist
not like physically dead but the group
is dead and we did a few sketches and it
kind of lit the flame of like this is
what I have been doing my whole life and
this is what I want to do and we
realized the two of us we should just
start our own we were doing with a group
of people and we weren't really doing
what we wanted to do so we started our
own sketch comedy group called joy camp
and shout out Joey camp and this was it
was like I was applying for jobs to be
an editor or a writer nothing was
working and when we started this it was
the beginning of everything for me so
the two of us got together with a couple
of other good friends our friend Gelman
who is Lee Newtons now husband yes one
of the funniest guys I've ever met my
whole life my friend Nick and and my
brother my brother would do all the
shooting for us and a few other friends
and so he started this group and we
started making videos for YouTube and
they they did okay they did pretty well
we got like up to like 17,000
subscribers and we found our little
niche audience and it was it opened all
the doors for me in this business
because first of all it taught me like
but to get better editing better writing
just more efficient in general lighting
all the stuff that it takes to do like
what we do here basically yeah and so I
built my resume doing that and then
that's how I started getting my
freelance editing jobs was from that and
I did a I worked for Roseanne Barr that
is noted
my notes right now should I go should we
go I'm sorry you go to your email but I
do want to talk about your resume and
your cover letter okay because it is
funny how directly so I'll get to the
email and we'll come back to that okay
so it got me a lot of jobs including
this one here at mythical entertainment
because your email you sent to studio 71
I believe mm-hmm my friend Mitch was
working for studio 71 in the New York
office I don't think he does anymore but
he was at the time so they sent it to
him saying hey do you know anybody that
is nice that they were spreading the
word like that yes
Mitch sent it to Nick the Varon a
YouTube group called the Clunes which
are great and Nick knew that I had been
putting feelers out for a job so he sent
it to me because Nick we had was doing
clean stuff and he didn't need a job so
he sent it on to me and I read it and I
was a REIT as I was reading it I was
like this sounds great like this sounds
like totally right up my alley so I
drafted up my email that I sent t I sent
it to Nick or to Mitch Mitch said he'll
sing my praises and I got really excited
and like I said it was very exciting for
me to get that email because I was on
the search for a couple of months and my
my bank account was just a pleading
living off of savings I was getting
nervous the holidays were coming up I
went to Trader Joe's I got an
application I was like I can do that for
a little while told the work comes in
and my unemployment so this is how crazy
this is
I came home one day it's like kind of
beating down from just nothing panning
out and I opened the mailbox and I had
my last unemployment check literally
like literally the last check that I got
from unemployment I go inside and I'm
like okay what the heck am I gonna do I
got my Trader Joe's application open up
my laptop and I had an email from you
only exactly and I just thought like
it's too good to be true so then you
basically set up an interview for me
mm-hmm at the old office mm-hmm which I
came into I was very excited about it
and very nervous because it was like the
three of you guys in the room who was
like rhett and Link right I always never
maybe interviews period whenever I have
the guys in an interview I'm always I
always forget that for whoever we're
interviewing it it makes
things even more like you know high
anxiety levels so much more seasoned it
was along they're very tall they are
really tall and it was shocking like
they were sitting pick on one side of me
and you were like on the other side of
me that was like flanked interview
etiquette I remember even when I
interviewed with them way back when we
met at a coffee shop and we were
standing in line to get food and I was
trying to talk to them I I knew who they
were at the time but you know and I was
like look like I literally it was like
trying to it was a situation that was
like okay but like anyway sorry so
interviewed I also have a when you came
in for your interview it was such a
small studio and I think that you are
really excited so you were talking in a
volume that was you could hear me louder
than and I remember thinking like this
guy talks so but I was like he's so nice
and he totally gets it and he's a
podcast fan and I really want to have
him and let's hope but he doesn't talk
that loud in real life and then you
didn't and I was like okay I was
probably nerves just like you kind of
like put under a microscope in those
situations and like the natural she's
just the talk really loud because
that'll make me better for some reason I
was dripping sweat when I came out I
didn't know if you guys knew that but I
walked out the first thing I did when I
got home was take a shower but when I
when I closed the door behind me I could
hear you guys oh no and I but I couldn't
tell it you said and it made it even
more nerve-wracking because I either
thought you guys said well that he well
he was awesome or well he was awful
oh no yeah I didn't know which one so
like the whole time that goes awesome we
also probably didn't say either there's
probably something unrelated yeah I was
all in my head but like the whole drive
home like they think I'm awesome no they
probably they think I'm awful
they think I'm awful not getting the job
but then I don't know was a few days
later I got another email and I was so
pumped because it was like a little
trial run thing that you guys gave me
I did and I think I did really well on
it and then I got you gave me they offer
me the position and it was like the
beginning of December yeah but I wasn't
starting till January yeah but it was
the best Christmas gift ever because it
was like I know I have a job in January
and now I get to enjoy the holidays like
with my friends and family so it was
like I mean you should have seen like
when I told Kate she was like jumping
for joy well let's jump to Kate because
I have a good Cape story - well I mean
that's no that's that's really which is
a word that rhymes with Kate is is
amazing and I'm glad that you're still
here and I feel like you've been here
for a very long no I'm old school
um Kate is your wife you know she used
to be your girlfriend
then she was your fiancee yes girlfriend
for like ten years really it was that
long on and off for eleven years and
then we got married and we've been
married for almost a year now
how's it going it's good people always
ask how's married life I'm like yeah
it's exactly exactly the same but it's
great but Kate has a secret it's not
actually a secret Kate is a twin she is
identical twin can we talk about that
for a second like so how did you guys
meet
so how did twins meet other people
actually I have a I made a video about
how we met for sorry I didn't see that
one for no you know I didn't I I meant
to slack it to everybody after the
wedding and then I forgot but I made it
specifically for the wedding yeah and
it's a it's one of those it's like a
spoof of like the drunk history thing
with her sister and I but I recorded
them the twist was they didn't know they
were being recorded
I just got audio of them and then I had
Delmon and my friend Benny play their
parts and reenact the whole story but
it's actually and you piece together
audio clips from them so that told the
story without them knowing so em it was
one night she got to put this somewhere
by the way now that we're talking about
it oh I just cut to a clip I'll be happy
to share it yeah cut to a clip this is a
walking that it can
and all I see Kevin I was like really
excited so I wasn't sat next to him
[Music]
and I think I'm so sorry you Kevin cuz
we're having really fun we're talking
about movies and books I was like I've
gotta go I've got to go find my sister
and say Zack we'll get him with you and
I was like okay and so we walked it was
awesome Rock right on a river
he's like bull let's sit here and so he
sat there and we talked for a while and
that's where we had our first kiss
[Music]
it's the only public video on my
personal YouTube channel because I use
that for like when I'm sending drafts of
editing people but that tells the whole
story pretty much in full but we met in
high school through my girlfriend at the
time Cassie
oh yes that's my girlfriend's name yes
it is she's awesome too
Cassie my girl yes our year Cassie she
was cool but your girlfriend's awesome
yes and we kind of knew each other off
and on in high school and then one day I
moved to San Francisco and my first
summer after living there for a year I
went camping at the Kern River and the
Kern River is not far from LA most
people don't know it's a couple hours
away but it was something that I did
with my guy friends frequently and
unbeknownst to me it was something that
she did with her family for a long time
and we just so happened to be there at
the exact same time and just so happened
to have a mutual friend that was there
that knew that we were both there that
brought everybody together and that's
pretty much where we hit it off and then
kind of dated on and off ever since yeah
at the Kern River and there's a lot more
to the story but it's all in that video
okay
well link to it yeah well cut to it yes
so so in high school you were like oh
there are these two there are these twin
girls yeah they're identical identical
twins and they've like isn't their story
where they they did fool you ones are
you almost were fooled they well they
they did that's like a very common twin
question for them as if they ever like
traded places and stuff and they did but
never specifically they've rumors story
about they've done like on the phone you
can't tell who which is which yeah it's
very difficult so there's been many
times where I've called and m's picked
up the phone and I've talked to her for
20 minutes so we don't think she's
actively trying to fool you or she just
want to talk to you like actively trying
to fool me so there's been a lot of
things like that one way but never
anything like super crazy hi this is my
Kate story and I can't remember was it
was it after VidCon it was after some
kind of convention in which or some trip
I was taking with Retton
whenever I go with rhettandlink anywhere
they get approached by a lot of people
and then I am standing there so they
have to say something to me like oh and
Stevie we know who you are too
and so I was in this mindset where that
week had been a lot of people
approaching me and talking about the
show
and um and I was I was feeling pretty
good about the show but like I had a
business lunch in our neighborhood and
Los Feliz and I was on the phone on the
way to a meeting and I like glanced to
my side I was waiting for the light to
change and for me to cross the sidewalk
and there was a really pretty girl who
was like in her 20s and she was wearing
a GMM hoodie but she was also wearing
sunglasses and a hat yeah and I was like
for my first thought was I really don't
want to like I don't know what this
interactions gonna be like we're waiting
to cross a sidewalk I don't know she's
gonna say to me I'm on the phone I have
to go to this meeting this is really
like I just panic when anyone approaches
me I just like I panic um and did you
teach me the technique I think of like
asking somebody what their name is yes I
think you can't tell you that because
that's what I use now is like I'm
immediately go to what's room because
I'm like oh that's a sentence is
complete right now at this moment and so
here I am thinking like well I feel
really good about our show because we're
in this cool neighborhood and this cool
girls wearing her sweatshirt and I'm
standing right here and we have fans and
then what had how did I find out it was
Kate like you texting me the same time
that she texted me because I thought
that it I had thought about it and then
was like oh wait yeah I had to
rationalize the situation I think she
said she was like saying hi but you were
like kind of a nervous like reaction to
her and I think it came off to you and
your mind it came off as like you dissed
her and to her in her mind she came off
of someone creepy so I got both these I
got a text message on one end from
cabling and I just creeped out Stevie
and one from UI
because just your girlfriend but then we
saw we resolved it yeah and and it was
all good yeah but the day that I do see
a cute girl in our 20s wearing a GMM
sweatshirt and las pilas
who's not your wife feel pretty pretty
cool now I do have one story that I have
shared with you at the time but with not
with any of the viewers which is my
proposal and I don't know how much time
we good on time right now cuz we're okay
okay so uh again I'll keep this one to
just the highlights but this is like one
of my favorite stories because it
involves me almost dying as well as Kate
too and her whole family so this is my
proposal story story book proposal story
we we went for we were camping in
Wrightwood which is a great camping
place outside of LA that I'm not a lot
of people here know for some weird
reason which is what makes it great and
we it's a been a ritual that we go there
and we go on these long hikes up this
thing called Mountain baden-powell this
thing it's a mountain we hike up a
mountain POW it's a very steep long hike
it takes like two and a half to three
hours to get up and a little shorter
getting down but it's very steep and
we've done it pretty much every year
that we've like together sound like like
at the top is there like this Oasis
where you're like yeah it's beautiful
year it is it's once you get to the top
it's so rewarding that you've made it to
the top and then you can kind of chill
out eats my food and there's there's a
log up there that we like carved our
names into years and years ago and so I
thought that'd be a great spot to do
that and since the whole family knew
that you were gonna they do that and it
was her whole family and me and her and
then when one of our friends was with us
too when we were just all like a big
camping group for a couple days she had
any idea that this was coming she kind
of had an inclination yeah she kind of
knew wasn't positive but she kind of
knew and so what I did was as long as
I've been with her I've always made what
I call like video albums of like
pictures compiled together of our time
together but I added it too you know
music like digital scrapbook yes exactly
okay and I've been doing that forever
it's did you know that the iPhone the
new does it have like an app that is
crazy yes like you can you go to your
camera okay maybe I see I just want to
show you I want to see it because this
will save me a lot of time in the future
it and I was like I was playing with
this for a very long time because it's
very creepy okay so here is let me see
if it does it with this one okay so here
is this photo I just shared on Instagram
oh you're one of the scenes and buddy
system okay I really like okay so when
you're in the your photos you just
scroll up and then it has related albums
I don't know if you've seen this feature
I have so then let's say I want to click
on July 13th which also looks like
season 1 a buddy system okay then I can
press play right here and it starts
doing a slideshow not only does it do a
slide music no let's see oh no there's
music is it from your library
[Music]
well I'll never have to make one of
those every no and look at this also
there's choices for what you want the
music to be so dreamy sentimental gentle
chill happy uplifting epic let's see
epic you just go to epic and I bet it's
gonna play epic music it is it's like a
it's a trailer and it's kind of NSYNC -
well now I'm not gonna be as cool if I
make another one of those videos how oh
come on you can not play with that
feature for hours I'm gonna admit it
hours oh I'll be playing with that for
hours tonight this podcast for sure okay
I'm sorry so that's what you did I did
that I didn't like labor into it and
like making yes things so I made that
for the proposal which I could only show
on my laptop so I had to bring my laptop
hop on the hike which was a long hike
like I said and it was much harder to be
up there having a laptop backpack on you
but we made it to the top I opened it up
showed the video to everybody did the
proposal was beautiful like the Sun was
out I'm guessing at the point when you
took out your laptop as one she really
knew something yes he was like huh we
got to watch a movie or something we're
up on top of this mountain so that went
great we all kind of celebrated and you
know tears and all that and then we made
our way she cry everybody did everyone
yeah everyone cried and then we made our
descent down the mountain and we noticed
in the far off distance there was this
big plume of smoke coming up it turns
out that there was a big accident on the
freeway which was like not terribly far
from the campgrounds but far enough and
it just kind of had the gave this like
sort of like ominous gloom - to
everything in that direction and then we
made our way back to town where we
usually stop and have dinner after the
hike and we saw it on the news there's
this big accident in this fire and then
the then it got really windy out in that
area there's like high
that are intense and we go back to our
campsite and the campsite is completely
destroyed the tents everything blown
over toppled over on the ground so we
start cleaning up and putting things
away and putting our tents back up and
during that time Kate started feeling
really sick so she comes down with the
flu
and she's now throwing up so she's
throwing up and the campsites back
together but it's really windy and she
says I'm gonna go to bed early it was
like 8 o'clock so I said okay well to
hide from the hike so he go to bed she's
kind of intermittently getting up to
throw up and then to come at sorry Kate
and it's a little embarrassing coming
back in the tent and then we finally
fall asleep everybody falls asleep and
then I'm awoken by the sound of our
friend shannon saying guys guys guys and
then I hear sirens oh my gosh I thought
I was dreaming
open the tent shannon is leaning in
she's like the mountain is on fire and
we're being evacuated
I was like come again so nice seeing you
goodbye in the total days you know you
get out of the tent and you and I look
around and it's everything's like kind
of coming to me and I see a cop coming
around with sirens going and he's on his
loudspeaker saying everybody must
evacuate the mountain the mountain is on
fire this is not a drill I repeat this
is not a drill and I see all these
campgrounds like rushing packing up and
me and Shannon are the only ones up in
our campground so I like have to wait
Kate up and the thing about Kate M is
when they get into deep sleeps they do
not wake up the flue especially when
they have the flu so it's panic starts
to set in and her dad and mom wake up
and then I'm like trying to piece things
together and I'm trying to wake up her
sister who will not wake up she is out
cold em Emily em the mountains on fire
wake up em and she's just laying there
dead asleep and her boyfriend gets up
and he was trying to wake her up but not
wouldn't work and everybody's kind of
taking their time like hooding likes
like the mom her mom was like folding
the table and I'm like no
the mountain is on fire the cop comes
around a second time the sirens blazing
I repeat this is not a drill
I look around everybody else is gone
except for us so I associate in two M's
ten and she took her the air mattress
and started doing this up and down with
it and emily is like flopping around
like a fish out of water still dead
asleep and then I get Kade up and she's
helping me and at this point I'm
grabbing everything I can grab and
throwing it into the car and her dad's
kind of doing the same a cop comes the
cop comes around the third time and he
says this is your final warning
you have to get off the mountain now the
fire is closing in on the only exit on
this mountain if you do not get off you
are stuck on this mountain and he's very
Stern seem very helpful give us a when
he was final warning that your life is
in jeopardy gotta go bye yeah see ya so
we've like at this point kind of yelling
at everybody just to get him we get
Emily up she immediately starts crying
just because she's like in a daze
doesn't know what's going on we're
yelling at her so she's crying I put her
in the car I get Kate in the car we get
everything that we can get packed up and
then Emily's boyfriend runs off to his
car he has a flat tire he's driving down
the thing in the flat yes I remember
everything gets progressively worse yes
I get in our car and then Don gets in
the camper that we have the truck that
pulls the camper and he's behind me and
I still see Carolyn her mom trying to
get stuff off the campground like
folding up chairs I'm like leaning out
the window late Carolyn get in the truck
let's go so she gets in the truck and we
finally start driving off and we turn
the bin and they were not kidding the
fire was coming over the top of the
mountain we were driving into the flames
it was - my heart was beating like am I
gonna be able to drive off this mountain
and if not there was no one like in
front of you or no one in front of us no
no it's pitch black except for these
gigantic flames coming over the hill at
those moments you kind of think like
isn't there's someone in the world right
now that's supposed to tell me what I'm
supposed to do right now kind of yes you
know it was it was honestly like in the
moment it's fun to tell it now but in
the moment it was absolutely terrifying
because like the heart's beating really
fast I'm driving into the flames and I'm
thinking is the eggs-it gonna be closed
and if it is what the heck are we gonna
do
turn around ditch the car and run down
this dark mountain in the middle of the
night probably so we had a plan yeah
running down a dark mountain away from
the fire we're going down the winding
road and we come around the last bend
and I'm like fingers crossed
please please please and sure enough the
flames hadn't quite hit it yet and it
was open so they kind of waved us
through we drove down the street even
m'boy friend at the time he got his car
off with a flat tire he parked it there
and then we go we pull off the street
and now M has come down with the flu so
M and K are on the side of the road it's
like 3:00 in the morning throwing up on
the side of the mountain and I'm
standing in the middle of the street
seeing like her family on the street
looking at this mountains it's just
engulfed in flames and I can't wait to
see the video that you used before the
fire before the actual fire but after
the romantic fire of yours yes well
Kevin I think that's our time okay thank
you I mean I just arbitrarily determined
that yeah that's good you have to stop
me because otherwise I could just keep
going on and on forever thank you so
much for being on crew biscuits great to
be here if you want more crew biscuits
let us know in the comments below and
thank you for listening and for watching
this is mythical and subscribing you've
been a great audience
you're the best why hello Stevie hey you
know I would love to because I actually
have not slept a single night since so
I'm gonna go ahead and eat you know I'm
just leaving written links office
because that's where I work when they're
off filming buddy system and now I'm in
I'm in that your biscuits room there's a
pan on the table so should I just sign
anywhere
that could be fair to Alex and the rest
of crew you gotta go okay
that sounds good to me okay I'm dropping
down now I'm gonna set the phone down
cuz I need okay here comes the pin cap
okay you hear that yeah
okay listen close I'm gonna sign you
hearing this yeah okay first name is
done here comes the last name yeah my
last name is kinda long but uh Stevie
you'll be happy to know that I have
signed the table you're welcome thanks
TV
you too but so it's been two and a half
years and I've worked here and I finally
got my name on the table which is
awesome
no Alex I'm the table before me he's
back here you can't really see it it's a
little bit of a scribble he kind of
dramatically decreased the value of this
table so I'm hoping that my signature
has brought that value back up but in
all seriousness it's an honor to be on
this table here thanks guys
[Music]